je le dis en télé et benjamin tu étais
il ya plein de mecs aussi et quand les
mecs sont pas reconnaissants à servir il
n'y a rien de pire et est aussi il ya
plein de gars comme ça où des mecs voilà
tu les as surtout quand ils sont pas
reconnaissants et qui en plus si tu
attaques assez ça donnait faut se
défendre quoi mais c'est normal mais si
sarah moi j'essaie mais de quelqu'un de
juste
aussi je pense on a des bosseurs donc la
trahison on l'a vu encore plus mal mais
c'est ça et souvent quand on croit que
c'est nous qui attaquons les mecs je
vous jure que c'est vrai et 99% du temps
on fait que répondre si je peux me
permettre vous aimez ça beaucoup tous
les deux aussi vous aimez en juin qu'en
mai oui je suis ultra c'est ça qu'on
c'est parti c'est parti ouais ouais
c'est ça tu cherches tu trouves ça à
partir de à partir du moment où tu te
mets en compétition contre moi faut
qu'il y en ait un qui reste au sol c'est
donc moi ça dure et noble mais un jour
tu m'as dit un truc on était au
téléphone ans on cherche à unir
survêtement parce que j'ai vu la bagarre
at je t'en parle pas mais j'ai vu la
bagarre avec à la baguette les bagarres
ou moi je suis victime bagarre bon bah à
jour tu m'as dit hôtel
tu m'as dit tous les deux des
l'opposition sama et gérer plus l'as tu
m'as nischni c'est vrai il a raison en
fait tiré que résistance s'est pas fait
c'est sale et à la piraterie comme ça
c'est quoi pour toi c'est la résistance
et la liberté un peu ouais on va pas se
plier à chaque règle et derek tonkin
sens mais vous est arrivé pardonner à
quelqu'un ça dépend le niveau de
exactement là niveau il ya plus de
retours genre d'écart ils ne savaient
pas de away tiens justement je crois
qu'à une question sur carrie c'est
delphine oui oui moi ma question c'est
ça qu'est ce que cariste pourrait faire
pour que vous fassiez enfin la paix
parce que là vous allez partir enfin
vous allez vous allez changer de vie
plus ou moins qu'est ce qui pourrait
faire pour que vous partiez un peu
apaisées ap ap à faire là c'est quoi
je crois tout à fait comblé
bernard montiel vous rappelez quand je
dis venue à la dernière fois skb quand
on avait reçu caris & vous étiez au
téléphone
est ce qu'il y avait vraiment de sa
grand mère dans la salle de gym enfants
bernard tu sais pas si j'ai aubin en 5
dès jeudi qu'elle avait 1,5 des mêmes